The myriad molars of modern mammals can be traced back to...
...a common form called "tribosphenic,"...
...which first appeared during the dinosaur age.
In the 19th Century, paleontologist Edward Drinker Cope...
...developed the basic model for how this form evolved.
He hypothesized that it started with a cone-like tooth,...
...as we see in many fishes, amphibians, and reptiles.
Small cusps were then added, so the tooth had three in a row,...
...aligned front to back, and connected by crests.
Over time, the cusps were pushed out of line to make triangular crowns,...
...adjacent teeth formed a continuous zigzag of crests for slicing and dicing.
A low shelf then formed at the back of each set of teeth,...
...which became a platform for crushing.
As Cope realized, the tribosphenic molar...
...served as the jumping-off point...
...for the radiation of specialized forms to follow,...
...each shaped by evolutionary needs.
Straighten the crests and remove the shelf,...
...and you've got the conveniently-bladed teeth of cats and dogs.
Remove the front cusp, raise the shelf, and you've got our human molars.
A few additional tweaks get you a horse or cow tooth.
Some details in Cope's intuitive hypothesis proved wrong.
But in the fossil record,...
...there are examples of teeth that look just as he predicted,...
...and we can trace the molars of all living mammals...
...back to that primitive form.